it's give back week here on the show and
we are shining a light on people and
organizations lifting up their
communities and often the world people
like our next guest she is a real woman
of action after seeing too many
tragedies in her Washington DC Community
she rallied a group of female leaders to
support the younger generation of black
women making a difference it's all
Grassroots and it's having a huge impact
everybody say hello to Asana
Smith welcome so explain it's the giving
Circle right explain the giving Circle
okay so it is a group of about 20 women
at this point and what we do is we have
a monthly fee that we all have to pay we
pay $70 a month yeah at the end of that
year we pull that money and then we
decide on which organizations in our
community that we'd like to invest in
yeah we have a committee that researches
and looks around for organizations that
are helping young black women and girls
really make a transition successfully to
adulthood and we figure out you know who
we want to invest in and we pull that
money and we give at least
$10,000 to all of organizations oh my
God so how did you come up with this so
I've always wanted to do a giving Circle
it was something that I learned about
early early on in my career but a
tragedy struck our community back in
2017 where a young girl who was um on
her way to college
just finished high school was a
cheerleader was in the was in a the
choir the dance troop all of these
things unfortunately her life was cut
short due to gun violence in Washington
DC and it just struck me that I really
wanted to do something more than what I
was doing yeah and so about a day after
my birthday uh my 42nd birthday so six
years ago I wrote a letter to 20 women
that were were other moms that I saw at
school some of my best friends some
lifelong friends and I said you all we
can do something more and we can do this
together I think the big thing was what
can we do that can make a huge impact
and we didn't have to do it alone and so
I thought so I came up with this idea of
let's do this giving Circle in honor of
making sure that every single young
black woman in our community can
transition successfully to adulthood
yeah and the kind of success that you
have had as well at 17 you're the whole
world is ahead of you you are you're
about to embark on So Many Adventures
and experiences and live your life and
just learn and reach your fullest
potential ideally and we just don't want
to see that cut short for more young
women and so the giving circle is really
focused on that absolutely oh my god
well your first grant it it was called
right for girls right yes so why why was
that your first one how'd that come
across your table so when we got the
circle together all the moms and the
leaders and all of us you know we have
our meetings um we picked two initial
areas of focus one was sort of like
physical health and awareness as young
women and then the other one was um you
know we really wanted to prevent or
eliminate the what we call the school to
prison Pipeline and one of the things
that kind of is in that bucket is human
trafficking of young girls um it's
happen everywhere it's definitely
happening in the DC region and uh rights
for girls and happening in the nation is
an organization that really tries to
prevent and eliminate that from
happening through policy and advocacy
work and keeping young women safe um and
making sure that they have access to
what they need to keep safe and so that
was our very first grant in 2018 yeah
$110,000 that's so amazing so where
where are you putting your efforts now
so fast forward to to six years later we
are close to giving out
$80,000 total
wow this year we had our biggest
fundraising year ever $20,000 we raised
and so we are giving all of that out
we're dividing that
$20,000 up um with three different
organizations and one of the ones that
we're really focused on this year is the
Black Swan Academy they work with DC
high school students young black DC high
school students to help them learn how
to become Civic leaders in their
communities to stand up for the issues
that are impacting them the most and
they are doing a great job of organizing
these young people and helping them to
have a voice in their communities
absolutely those live skills are
invaluable joining us now is the founder
of one of those groups from Black Swan
Academy let everybody Welcome Samantha
what's up
Samantha thank you for being here and
explain Black Swan Academy yeah so Black
Swan Academy we create a pipeline of
black youth Civic leaders in middle
school and high school so what that
means is we teach them the skills the
tools and give them the opportunities to
be the change agents that they are to
make a difference in their communities
and to be the experts that they truly
are absolutely earing instilling at them
from the beginning that's amazing what
kind of success have you seen so a lot
of success so from our young people
identifying the issues in their
communities and they'll also identify
the solutions uh from policy Solutions
so they passed some legislation they
gotten more money out allocated in the
city budget for mental health services
for housing for violence intervention
and then outside of that we also see now
we're almost 10 years old and so some of
our young people that started in seventh
grade are about to graduate from college
um some of them have started their own
families um they're getting into law
they're getting into politics they're
getting into entrepreneurship and then
we have our little eighth graders or
seventh graders who are winning awards
at their schools for most improved or
who are graduating some of them top of
their class and so we just see both the
external impact with our advocacy with
our systemic change the impact in our
community through our service work but
also the impact that they have in their
individual lives and with their families
that's
incredible so what does it mean to
receive this money to get this support
from the giving Circle everything right
so for our organization that is focusing
on black young people it is absolutely
pivotal that they see other black people
pouring into them and investing into
them and so to be able to be gifted by a
black woman L um giving Circle they're
able to see that the solutions can come
from our communities that the people who
look like us care about us um and to see
that reflection of what's possible as
they grow into their adulthood
absolutely and receiving it from people
that it's also a light at the end of the
tunnel to see like what you can achieve
yeah absolutely what you can what's
possible absolutely so do you have
something you want to say to Samantha I
think you did right
well Samantha we are just the bridges
Beyond 17 fund is extremely grateful to
be able to support you all because you
are creating the next generation of
leaders that we need in this country
that we need in our communities and we
just couldn't be happier to support you
and just thank you for everything that
you do you do and your vision for
founding
this so many people are so impressed
with what you've done and our friends at
Wing drone delivery offer fast delivery
of Home Essentials food and medicine to
your doorstep by drone that's cool and
let 30 minutes or less that's even
cooler they they love the work Black
Swan Academy is doing and want to help
so they're donating
$25,000 to
help yes oh here I'll this up can I give
you a oh my God yes oh my God
you SM good too yes yes I was like wait
we're so proud and you know what I think
is really cool too is within your
community you're doing it this is such a
this could be such a cool domino effect
for everybody to learn from like you
know there's a lot of people we were
talking about in the commercial break
like I a lot of friends that they want
to help they have the money to help they
don't know where to do it like maybe
these giving circles popping up in your
community is so important and then you
find the people that already have these
programs and then you can just pour into
them it's an amazing idea for everyone
to do anybody can do it you $50 a month
$25 a month $75 a month whatever you can
give pull it bring it together yeah and
we can do so much to help especially
within your own Community if everybody's
doing that in their own communities
imagine everyone has something to give
we say every dollar counts and people
think that's cliche but truly every
dollar counts yeah thank you so much
this was such a beautiful story to even
get to share with everybody we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody thank you guys yall have a
great night I'm going
home